hello everyone welcome back to your once
per week systems design video I am
Jordan so today I'm going to try and
make it through this thing in one take
however I did eat like four quest bars
at work and I am currently sitting in
the smell of my own farts now not to say
that I'm running out of memory or
anything but I have been garbage
collecting a lot and I may need to take
a heap dump anyways let's go ahead and
get into this thing so today we are
covering Ticket Master I've said it
before I'll say it again I don't like
this problem the reason being it's
freaking handig ous anyways let's try
and get into it and I can try and deal
with the ambiguity so Ticket Master if
uh for whatever reason you don't have it
in your country I'm actually not sure if
it's just American is a site where you
can buy and sell tickets uh for concerts
or shows or any other sort of venue
event that sells them so for example if
we've got ourselves a Taylor Swift
concert it would basically have some
layout of the map like so where you've
got your stage in the middle and then a
bunch of different sections with the
seaing prices within each section so you
know Taylor Swift is pretty hot right
now and uh those tickets are going for a
lot of money as a semi Swifty myself I
don't think I will be investing so let's
do some problem requirements which again
are pretty ambiguous for this type of
site because they don't all work the
same way but okay number one like I
mentioned they're just going to be
events that we can go ahead and buy
tickets for number two is going to be
that upon clicking uh for an actual seat
that you want you can make a claim to it
right so when I say I want to get seat X
I have 5 minutes to go ahead and
purchase seat X and so the issue with
this type of claiming behavior is there
are a few different ways of implementing
this and I don't mean in technology I
mean like in terms of behavior like when
I claim it is it going to be the case
that uh everyone else can just like jump
on that ticket after I give it up or is
it going to be the case that you know we
have some sort of weight list for doing
so or we not going to do any claiming at
all who knows I certainly don't but I'll
try and cover
everything okay let's do some very crude
capacity estimates um as the sleuth that
I am I actually went to Ticket Master
and checked out how many shows there
were in New York City and there were
around 4,000 so scaling that up to
around the size of America by population
that would mean there's probably around
100 to two thou 200,000 events at one
time that we can purchase tickets for
and so let's really ballpark this thing
and say imagine each event has 100
different sections that uh tickets can
fall in and each section has 100
different seats if I now went ahead and
assume that every single seat could be
represented by the following Tuple right
the event ID the section ID the row ID
and the actual seat number and then also
like I mentioned we want to be able to
claim this thing and then subsequently
book it so something like a claim user
ID and maybe potentially a Boolean as
well to just say whether or not it's
actually been booked uh but again if
we're just assuming the above that's
basically five Fields where each of them
can be modeled as an integer and if so
that's four bytes per integer totaling
20 bytes and then again we're going to
multiply that by the number of events
times the number of sections times the
number of seats so we only actually have
to store around 20 GB of data at a time
uh for our seats that are bookable you
know obviously for historic bookings
we're probably going to have a lot more
data than this over time uh but the
point is if we're actually only trying
to Service uh users for active events we
don't actually need that much storage
and so what we're going to talk about
later in this video is the potential
utility of doing so in memory uh because
we're going to want some slightly more
complex functionality depending on how
we want to do these ticket claims and uh
yeah we'll get into that in a bit so
like I mentioned probably more for
historic bookings but uh you know we can
just use a normal database there keep
that all on hard disk okay so let's
discuss some actual possible approaches
to how we want to deal with our problem
so I'm going to discuss three uh and I
will probably ditch the first in a
second and then we'll mainly discuss the
last two in this video so the first is
like I the first thing is that I
mentioned the problem's ambiguous I
mentioned that we want to be able to
claim a ticket but how can we actually
do so so the first could be that you
know we just claim tickets after we pay
for them right I pay for one now I have
it if me and someone else are trying to
pay for a ticket at the same time
whoever enters our payment information
and clicks that confirm button first is
going to win uh so this could work but
at the same time it's probably a pretty
bad user experience right because I'm
not going to figure out that I didn't
get the ticket until I've already done
all this work maybe i' had to sign into
my account maybe i' had to enter my
credit card information and so generally
speaking I do think a lot of these like
ticket selling sites do not actually
work this way uh because of that
inconvenience so we're probably not
going to go into this one too much if we
did uh it would be pretty simple go to a
database whoever writes first wins grab
a lock if you have to whatever number
two is that tickets are going to be
claimed with a tte or a time to xpre
before we actually buy them right so I
say oh I want to go to the Taylor Swift
concert I see a couple of open seats I
click I want these seats and now all of
a sudden I have a FIV Minute Timer where
I can go ahead and check that out so
that's great but it also does actually
have some downside which is that if all
of a sudden I take longer than my
5-minute allotment now all of a sudden
anyone can make the next claim it's
possible that someone else you know was
thinking about purchasing that ticket
first but now all of a sudden you've got
five other people trying to get it at
the same time and of course when you do
have a bunch of other people trying to
do something at the same time we can run
into Thundering Herd problems in our
actual back end so we'll have to discuss
those as well the next thing is that uh
if we want to make this more fair right
where you know say I'm in line to get a
ticket I drop out the next person in
line actually gets them rather than some
other Rando who jumped in what would be
great is if we could have some sort of
weight list right a fifo weight list so
fifo just means first in first out uh if
I get there and then you get there
behind me and then a third guy comes
behind you uh you have priority after I
drop out so again this is going to be
the most fair but it is also not so easy
to implement we're going to discuss some
of the caveats associated with actually
doing that and uh we'll go through them
so the first thing to actually discuss
is this kind of unfair claim right
because I mentioned that the option
three was the the quote unquote Fair one
so I'll call option two unfair and I'm
not going to cover option one because I
think that for the purposes of a systems
design video it's pretty trivial okay so
option one is going to be that unfair
claim right where whenever I express
interest in buying a ticket assuming
that no one else has a claim on it I can
actually have five minutes to go ahead
and check it out so the first thing
that's going to happen here is I can
claim seat n and 10
uh user two afterwards can try and claim
seed 10 so that he can go check it out
and then the database is going to say no
user one already has a claim on that so
a couple things to note right here right
we are going to need our rights to be
both Atomic and serializable the reason
being that uh you know if I try and
submit a claim for both N9 and 10 and
only the claim for seat 9 goes through
well that's no use to me because then
someone else can check out C10 in the
meantime additionally if uh it is not
serializable I could submit a claim for
seat 9 and 10 and then somehow like in
the middle of that basically this guy's
claim for seat 10 could go through and
now all of a sudden I have a split claim
which isn't going to work when I claim
seats uh I want to either be able to get
them or I don't want to be able to get
them and it's that simple I should get
All or Nothing cool so the way that we
would do this uh with modern databases
um assuming we didn't want to implement
all of that locking on our own is
probably by using a transactional
database uh now the ones that are
typically going to be implementing
something like that would be SQL
databases you could use my SQL or post
grass or something like that some of the
nosql ones do have them but uh let's
keep things simple here because we don't
need any crazy right through put at
least for the moment that being said it
is still possible that we do want to
increase our right throughput right like
it is going to be the case that certain
events are going to have a lot of
traffic and if that's the case something
like partitioning might actually be able
to help us uh distribute our load over
multiple partitions so that that way one
database node isn't getting completely
completely overloaded so again uh the
idea is we have all these transactions
so that we want to um avoid like partial
claims like I was mentioning before uh
but the issue is if we're dealing with
partitions uh in order to help reduce
our load on every single partition now
we run the risk of actually having a
distributed transaction right if a seat
uh if seats were on two different
partitions and I wanted to make a claim
on seats that were in two different
partitions that would be bad so how
could we avoid this well actually
we could go ahead and basically make it
so that every single row is on the same
partition right because if I know that I
want to book two seats and I'm always
going to be booking two seats within the
same row uh having a given row on the
same partition is going to allow us to
avoid distributed transactions so
hopefully that makes a decent amount of
sense distributed transactions are slow
because they require us to do a
two-phase commit and that is going to be
very bad we have to coordinate basically
between both partitions and go back and
forth twice over the network which is
not ideal so again like I mentioned this
guy could be on one
partition and maybe it's you know row
two Row three and row six are on
partition one and then Row one row four
and row five are on partition two or
something like that we can balance them
out so let's continue to talk about
partitioning a little bit because it's
not so simple as I've just made it seen
uh like I mentioned we want the key to
be some combination of the event ID the
section ID and the row number and then
basically we can take some hash of that
and then use the actual hash range of it
to try and partition the rows relatively
evenly right so that there are a similar
number of rows on every single node by
using consistent hashing we can ensure
that not only are there similar numbers
on every single node but that if a node
were to go down or a node were to be
added to the cluster we would ideally
have minimal rebalancing so again not
all rows are going to be equal
unfortunately like with most actual uh
systems we can have hotspots right a
Taylor Swift concert at the end of the
day is going to be uh a lot more popular
than the example I used right here which
is the Dogecoin Summit in uh 20124 I
wouldn't think there are too many people
going to that so again how can we handle
the fact that certain rows are going to
get a lot more users that are interested
in them rows or sections we could
Partition by section as well if we
wanted to make them a little bit less
granular but the idea is the same you
know if I just post a Taylor Swift
concert the first you know 20 or 30
minutes there might actually be a ton of
traffic there well of course uh the
general idea is if we have a certain
node that is going to be overloaded
option one is going to be we can you
know repartition on that uh on that row
right so we would take say there were 10
uh rows on that partition already you
know now we take five of them and throw
them on a different partition so that's
an option and then the other which I
also think is pretty compelling here is
to actually use a right back cache so
like I mentioned uh for uh these kind of
hot rows we tend to know in advance
right which ones are are going to be
popular I know right after posting like
a Drake concert or a Taylor Swift
concert that it's likely that thing is
going to be hot for a little bit and so
this actually provides us with the
opportunity to basically uh route all of
the requests for that note to a specific
cach instance right I could put it in
redus or mcash or even just a dedicated
server but putting it in memory is going
to allow us to speed up those requests
so basically uh like I mentioned we
probably know which row is going to be
popular in advance and then from there
we can go ahead and do our back cashing
so uh we can basically just have redis
answering all of our claim requests and
then asynchronously in the background
once uh our our bookings are completely
done right we can do both the the claims
and the bookings on
redus and then in the background
asynchronously we'll go and throw
everything over to our SQL database now
keep in mind that uh redus is kind of
weird because it's single threaded so
I'm not actually too sure how this would
work in practice but maybe rather than
Rus I'll just say arbitrary inmemory
server with some amount of
locking which might speed things up in
comparison to uh redus which is single
threaded uh but you know we would have
to test this out in reality and then
again we'll sync all of that data to our
database eventually when uh traffic dies
down a little bit cool so the right back
cach would be temporarily our source of
Truth
okay now let's talk about another aspect
of this kind of UN Fair claiming
Behavior which is going to be claim
expiration right so if you recall I
mentioned that after a certain few
minutes if I don't actually go and check
out uh my claim is going to expire and I
won't be able to actually grab those
tickets until I make another claim so
how can we go ahead and do this well for
starters we definitely don't want the
claim expiration triggered by like an
additional networking request on the
client device right like the client
device isn't going to be like hey I've
waited 5 minutes now I have to go back
to the database and say hey it's been 5
minutes minutes I no longer have this
claim why well for starters uh client
devices May no longer be connected to
the network uh they may no longer be
connected to our site uh they may be
malicious and not want to expire their
claim all of which would be pretty bad
so another option we could use
potentially is a stored procedure right
where I invoke some function on the
database itself and I'm actually not
sure which databases would even support
this type of thing where uh you know 5
minutes later it goes and and cleans up
your claim um or uh which I think is
probably going to be the easiest in this
case is just whenever I make my initial
claim uh put an expiration timestamp on
the database which is 5 minutes later
and that expiration timestamp of course
will have to be generated by the
database itself otherwise malicious
clients could just you know put a claim
there that's uh you know forever in the
future so uh I write to the database
saying give me a claim database says
okay what's my current time let's add 5
minutes that's when this expires so
imagine we have the following row in a
database right we've got for seat 22 uh
user 40 currently is the claim the
claim's going to expire at 4:00 and
we're not currently booked so the
combination of the claim user ID and the
claim XPR is itself a fencing token
right so we've discussed this a little
bit in my systems Design Concepts video
but the point is a fencing token is
basically extra data that you can pass
back to the client so that when they
eventually try and go do something else
later we can validate that they are the
proper client that should be making this
request so I'll demonstrate that in a
second basically initially you know user
40 is going to make this claim to the
database and the database is going to
say okay your fencing token is 40 comma
4:00 meaning when you actually want to
book those tickets you're going to have
to pass me back 40 comma 4:00 or else I
know that it's someone else trying to
book these tickets and they don't
actually have the proper information
right no other client is going to be
able to uh read this row directly from
the database we're just not going to
expose it from the server as an API
request and so so as a result when I say
40 comma 4:00 I know that uh we should
actually be able to book this row okay
so uh request number one is going to be
you know user 39 says hey wait a second
I had a claim expiring at 359 guess what
buddy your claim is expired so it's not
going to be you who's booking it you can
also have a malicious client saying oh
I'm user 39 but my claim expired at 4:00
sorry Charlie not going to work and then
you know same thing with uh user 40 even
though he currently is the
this is basically user 40 uh coming back
later and saying oh you know I actually
had this old claim like let me uh let me
book uh no we're not going to because
the current claim is something different
right it expires at 4:00 now and yours
is from the 355 iteration so no luck
sorry eventually when the user comes
along and he says hey I'm user 40 and my
claim expires at 4:00 we can go ahead
and match these two up say hey this
thing looks good and then switch our no
to a yes we're booked now so hopefully
that makes a little bit of sense cool so
like I mentioned what are some of the
issues that we have when trying to deal
with these kind of unfair claims so
basically number one is that if I myself
uh do not have a claim and someone else
does but I want it I don't really have
any way of knowing that uh I don't have
the claim unless I'm pretty much
spamming um spamming the database uh
figuring out whether or not I got the
claim successful
so spam is going to be number one uh
number two is that let's imagine that
you know we can fix our spam by having
uh the database you know tell everyone
in real time uh via some sort of long
poll or some web hook or some server
sent event uh when the seat is actually
unclaimed again or when the seat claim
has expired well that's not particularly
ideal either because all of these guys
are going to get that message at the
same time and then they're all going to
try and stake their claim uh which like
I mentioned earlier is going to be a
thundering
HT so if I've got a 100 people here and
they all want to make the claim now all
of a sudden we just incurred a crap ton
of load on our database and we could
bring it down so ideally um you know
rather than just having this
free-for-all whenever a claim uh expires
what would be a lot better is if we had
some sort of weight list right where uh
we've got you know user number one user
number two and user number three and
when these guys all find out that the
thing is open well guess what user
number one is still the only one who's
allowed to book so ideally that would
make things a little bit
easier however Fair claim is itself also
not that simple because of the fact that
now we have to actually care about the
dependencies of people's claims so let's
go ahead and figure out what this slide
is talking about basically let's imagine
we have two seats right we've got a seat
one on the left seat two on the right
and we've got user one that's claims
seat one and user two so this is user
one this is user two on the
right and so what's now going to happen
basically is we say Okay user two is
going to drop out right and so our
priority ordering was that user 3
claimed both seat one and seat 2 after
user one and user two did and then the
last thing that happened was that user 4
went ahead and also staked their claim
on uh c 2 but
implicitly you know they're waiting
behind user 3 so they're actually
dependent on user 3 to finish assuming
that we are respecting fifo ordering now
the problem is here is that user one is
not done booking right so user one can
take forever to book or you know however
long it is until their claim expires and
in a real crappy situation what would
happen is you know not only just user
one was staking on claim one but we have
a whole chain of users over here
and then this guy you know rather than
directly staking on seat one basically
staked his clan behind all of these guys
so now he's first in priority over here
and fourth in priority over on the left
and so the question is does user four
have to wait for user 3 to completely
drop out until he books because that
could be a while or does user 4 just get
to say you know what I'm actually only
waiting for this guy so I get to cut the
line and you know Screw user 3 and the
point is it's actually kind of UN clear
I don't know what we would do I'm not a
ticket booking site but I do actually
have what I would consider to be a
middle ground solution which I think
makes things relatively fair for
everyone okay so I guess the issue more
or less is that uh we can summarize
things like this you know if we are
allowed to select the exact seats that
we're trying to book you can have
complicated dependencies in terms of our
cues right because I can want multiple
seats you can only want one seat but
maybe I put that claim down before you
did who actually wins it's kind of
unclear so again the the two issues now
is that if you were to try and put a
claim down on a lot of seats if it's
always the case that you're only allowed
to book uh you know if all of your
dependencies are resolved now all of a
sudden I want to claim three different
seats and that's going to be very hard
so I'm never going to be able to book or
in the contrary example where I just am
allowed to basically back up everyone
else waiting behind me even though I
want three seats and I've only gotten
access to one of them well now all of a
sudden I'm going to hold everyone else
back so I have this little graphic here
on the bottom of the screen just to to
illustrate that so let's imagine user
6 is basically going uh to you know user
6 is going to basically be over here and
it's got uh claims on all three of these
seats and now all of a sudden user
Eight's going to drop out uh now user 6
is now first first online for seat
number two over here and then user 9 is
between uh behind user 6 now user 9
might think oh wait I'm second online
I'm actually about to get this thing but
the reality of it is because user 10 is
over here and uh taking their sweet time
user 9 is never actually going to figure
out uh that they're you know going to
have to wait a while before getting the
seat maybe they would prefer to get in
line for a different seat uh similarly
another you know kind of bad thing would
be again user six is claiming all three
seats uh user 8 is going to drop out so
user 6 uh got priority on seat number
two before user 9 did but because user 6
is not number one right user 10 is first
in priority for seat number one user 6
uh does not have all of its dependencies
resolved in terms of making the booking
and so as a result number nine is able
to cut so either of these scenarios are
not ideal hopefully that makes enough
sense so what's another possibility that
we could actually do
to do this kind of fair claim algorithm
while also not either allowing a bunch
of people to cut or allowing uh a bunch
of people to get blocked and not figure
out that they're going to be waiting for
a super long time to hear back well one
thing that I've come up with here is
actually just not letting users select
their specific seats but rather they
would just select a row or a section and
in our back end we assign the user a
certain amount of seats based on the
number they're asking for right so let's
say a person comes along and he says hey
he we've got this whole row right here
here I'll uh I'll erase everything and
then we can uh demonstrate it all at
once I've got this whole row right here
these are all open seats each of these
boxes so user one comes along and says
hey I want four seats user one gets
there first our server says oh
everything's empty we can assign you
from the left right now user two comes
in and says hey I want two seats our
server says okay that's fine again I see
two seats right over here user three
comes in and says I want three seats our
server says ooh actually there are only
two left
sorry buddy you're out no sir user four
then comes in and says I want two seats
again we say oh wait we actually do have
two seats available let's go ahead and
book it for you so again this is
actually going to you know uh enable us
to get in a situation where we can
respect claims that got there earlier
first uh while also not blocking
everyone else right because in this case
uh even though user 3 was never going to
be able to get these seats they aren't
blocking user 4 we can just reject user
3 and then let user 4 book so again as
long as we process these requests in the
order that they're coming in this is
totally fine and uh I think it is a
feasible enough
option cool so the next thing we'll
actually talk about is uh the data model
that we're going to be using to do this
type of thing so as you could imagine
because we're trying to implement some
sort of waiting list uh typically what
we want to do is use a type of queue
right so we can actually take those
requests as they come in and you know
imagine there's a ton of them at a time
such that our server can't handle all of
them at once we want to buffer them in
some sort of either link list or a queue
or anything like that so let's Implement
a queue with a length list why not so
imagine we get order one two seats order
two with four seats is pointing to that
order three with three seats is pointing
to that and then order four with two
seats is pointing to that now if our
server is multi-threaded it's worth
noting that we are going to have to lock
on the last uh node of our length list
so that we can actually append a new
node to the length list that's just how
uh it goes when you're multi-threading
and then at least on the right over here
we want to DQ from our link list and
actually handle right we would say oh
there are two seats available so this is
going to user number one and this is
going to user number one and now that
that's done we can go ahead and pop this
guy so another thing uh that we could
also in theory do is you know we don't
necessarily have to process these one at
a time right we can pop pop this guy
because we know there are enough seats
left to handle it we can pop this guy
left to handle it we don't have to
process them completely one at a time uh
but then once we say oh wait you know
what there only two seats left now all
of a sudden we can't pop this guy so
worth noting uh but you know
optimization if nothing else and then
the last element of this is that people
are going to frequently want to leave
the queue right if I've been in for 10
minutes and I don't see myself getting a
ticket maybe I want to go try and book
another show so I say I'm ready to leave
this thing well this is where we want to
make uh you know leaving from the Q
efficient removing a node from it and so
actually one common uh database uh or
you know data structure and algorithm
kind of hack that we can do right here
is rather than just using a typical
linked list we can use a doubly link
list with a hashmap right so now I've
got uh like one is pointing here these
this is uh the keys of my map if it's
not clear two is pointing here three is
pointing here and four is going to point
all the way over there and so the point
is this can give us removes uh from our
W link list in O of one time because our
hashmap is going to tell us where our
node lives and then we can actually use
our doubly link list edges to get rid of
this guy in O of one time right we just
modify them so that this guy. next is
pointing to this guy.
next I don't really want to go into this
too much it's going to get messy but
hopefully you understand why these are o
of1
deletes so we can use a w link list with
a
hashmap okay in terms of expiring
unfillable orders like I mentioned
occasionally we're going to get orders
in our linked list which are simply
unfillable because there are too many
seats left so what can we actually do to
expire them well I would say option one
is going to be we actually just wait for
that order to get to the front of the
queue to cancel it so that's option
number one uh and the good part about
this is It's deficient right I never
actually have to like go through the
doubly link list in hashmap and remove a
bunch of order ERS arbitrarily from the
middle of it that being said uh now all
of a sudden you know if I've been
waiting for 10 minutes in the queue I
actually don't know if it's that my
order is unfillable or I just haven't
gotten to the front of the queue yet
right we don't want to actually delay in
telling users when their order is no
longer fillable because otherwise they
might wait in that line longer than
necessary we should just let them know
hey it's not going to happen and then
they can get out of there so that's
probably not going to be ideal I think
what would be better is basically
whenever we process an order and the
number of remaining seats actually
changes then we can go through and
expire all of those unfillable entries
right so now all of a sudden hey we've
only got uh two seats left oh wait this
guy is unfillable let's get rid of it
something like
that cool so now all of a sudden we have
our active order expiration like I
mentioned as the number of seats changes
we want to get rid of the nodes that we
can't support anymore so one option uh
and we're just going to do a little bit
of data structures here cuz why not is
that we do a Treet index of the orders
by size why do I say a Treet well
because you know say I want to find all
of the orders where there are you know
where they're requesting more than two
seats right so greater than two is what
I care about then I can quickly Traverse
this thing in O of log n
time actually I suppose it would
technically be linear because we could
grab up to the entire size of the tree
but the point is it's sufficient because
it's sorted and then I aggregate these
two sets right here you know find all
sets with seats greater than two so it's
going to be uh or rather find all
elements with seats greater than two
that's going to be these orders right
over there and then I can delete them
all from our link list with hashmap and
again all of those deletes are in O of
one time now of course because there are
five of these you know you're really
doing five deletes so 0 a five or
whatever you want to call it but uh
point is yes uh it should be relatively
efficient from an algorithmic comple uh
standpoint that being said uh this guy
does actually have some cons because for
starters now all of a sudden we're
augmenting how much storage we need we
need like a secondary index uh because
now we're indexing all the orders by how
big they are and then additionally every
single time that we read this tree right
here we need to grab locks on the actual
tree set itself to go and iterate
through it and similarly that's going to
contend with all of our incoming orders
because when we get an incoming order we
have to actually put it in the tree set
and now all of a sudden we have to have
locks on uh the incoming order and
actually deleting expired orders and as
a result of that there's going to be
some contention so maybe it's actually
not ideal and uh additionally there's a
little bit of time that it takes to go
and write an order into this right like
if I have another order uh for size 4
and it's order 10 now all a sudden I
have to put it over here so I have to
find the node for four and then I have
to add it at the end of the list which
is going to take a little a little
bit cool so what's another option that
could maybe be a little bit better is
actually going to be iterating through
the queue itself and deleting the
invalid elements right so the the thing
is you know if there's a ton of elements
in this list that's not ideal because
now all of a sudden every single time
that we handle an element right every
single time that we accept and book in
Order we now have to go back all the way
through this queue uh but at the same
time uh at least in my opinion this
actually might reduce contention when
locking the reason being that uh we can
basically remove nodes in the middle of
our link list uh without contending with
either the start or the end node right
because whenever our Handler is pulling
from the start to actually process an
order it needs to grab a lock on this
guy right here and similarly whenever
new orders are coming in it has to grab
a lock on the last node in the queue so
that it can basically add an edge to
that however if we're removing a node
from the middle of of our doubly link
list uh we actually only need to grab
locks on the two nodes that are on
either side of the node that we're
removing and assuming that this node is
somewhere in the middle of our length
list ideally the locks that we grab
won't have to contend with either the
Handler lock or the incoming request
lock and so as a result of that maybe
there would be less contention again if
we're doing this type of thing like
fully in redus this is all going to be
single threaded and this wouldn't really
be much of a concern but I do figure
that I'll bring it up because a lot of
these typ typ of programs are
multi-threaded at the end of the day and
when that's the case you do actually
have to think about
locking cool so the last thing that I
want to mention uh or the second to last
rather is actually going to be
partitioning and the gist of this one is
that partitioning is going to work
basically identically to how we already
mentioned it uh again you know keeping
every single row on the same partition
will ensure that if I want to book
multiple seats in the same row I can do
so without having to go to multiple
different partitions at a time that
being said of of course there are going
to be certain hot row right like the
Taylor Swift rows are going to be a lot
more popular for bookings than the
Insane Clown posi AKA jigo if you
haven't heard of them yeah those are fun
so uh the gist is here that um again if
we take those popular rows and we
isolate them out to their own partition
because we know in advance which ones
are going to be popular uh that could
help us reduce the load on each of these
nodes a little bit maybe mitigate it the
last element of this is going to be data
storage so when I you watched my old
video on Ticket Master one of the things
that I really didn't like about my
design was that I actually involved a
two-phase commit basically from this
linkless cache right over to dis where
we would actually hold the bookings
right because every single time this
Handler runs it is going to be not only
deing something from the link list but
also adding something to the database
and so that would require a two-phase
commit to keep them completely
consistent now that is going to be very
slow and when we want to keep load uh or
rather when we want to keep this process
moving of handling orders having to do
some sort of synchronization over the
network is definitely not ideal so what
I propose instead is basically actually
using uh the inmemory uh linked list and
you know basically uh a map within that
node as our source of Truth so not only
do we have the linked list there to
store our priorities but we also just
keep um a separate hashmap of basically
the seat to who booked it and that way
we can not only perform replication on
this node to another node but but we can
also asynchronously send out that data
to Kafka and then sync it via a consumer
into an actual bookings database so this
is going to mean that all of our
historical bookings are within a
bookings database and then basically
whenever uh our seats within a row are
completely cleared out or the event has
actually happened uh we can clear out
all of the state that we've built up in
memory uh which is going to include you
know the the link list itself and also
just that map of you know whose seats
are actually going to to be booked to so
yeah using change data capture is going
to ensure that we don't have to like
fully wait on this right going to the
database before continuing to process
more elements I would think that the
combination of the right ahead log uh
you know the asynchronous
replication to another similar link list
type node plus the change data capture
through Kafka and into the bookings
database should be enough for fault
tolerance I suppose that without some
form of distributed consensus uh it's
not guaranteed that we won't lose a
single right if uh you know this guy
were to just get completely nuked
forever uh before one of these guys got
sent over um but at the end of the day
uh it's Ticket Master it's not life or
death if one booking gets screwed up
they can call customer support and we
can always fix
it cool so the last element of this
problem is actually going to be going
through the design formally so the first
thing is that we are going to have some
sort of load balancer right when the
client says Hey I want to go ahead and
book a ticket and so we're going to hit
the load balancer it's going to direct
us to one of the partitions for our
order claim servers now keep in mind
this is both maintaining the weight
lists for every single row as well as
actually storing the information about
which uh seats within a row are going to
be booked so we can partition those on
the event ID in combination with the
section ID and the row ID like I
mentioned just use a hash range
partitioning keep things consistent and
then once we go ahead and get paired up
with one of these guys let's imagine
it's right here we can go establish some
sort of real-time connection like a
websocket so that way I'm actually
capable of knowing what position in the
queue that I am the next aspect of this
is going to be that from here like I
mentioned we've got some sort of
asynchronous
replication because between a write
ahead log to make sure that if this guy
went down it keeps its state plus
asynchronous replication to basically
another you know you know kind of
waiting Q replica we can then also do
change data capture to sync all of our
data onto disk right so uh it's going to
put it into the appropriate partition
ideally we partition our bookings data
uh database by user ID the reason being
that if I'm a user and I would like to
see all the tickets that I've bought it
would be great if those were all on one
partition so again we're just throwing
these into a bunch of different kfka qes
uh some sort of consumer is going to be
getting those it hit some sort of load
balance there to say oh I see there's
user ID X for this booking which one of
these database partitions is it going to
and of course all of these data
partitions are themselves
replicated we can just do single leader
to keep it simple just so we don't lose
the data plus also uh those uh replicas
can themselves serve requests and then
finally you know if this guy wants to
see hey like why don't we uh go get my
bookings a load balance in conjunction
with some sort of booking service
right
bookings
service can go reach out to the proper
partition of the database and then fetch
their results okay guys well it turns
out I was able to make it through this
video my voice is hurting a little bit
but we've gotten through it I hope you
all enjoyed it I will see you in the
next one